one of the big debates over in loudoun
county is about critical race theory
that's not a debate anymore
governor ron desantis put an end to it
one of the many things he's done
to stay ahead of the curve and what's
happening in our country in our society
especially in florida governor welcome
back good morning
good morning how you all doing doing
okay it's a friday yeah
i mean that issue that we're handling
and loud and behind almost on a daily
basis
why did you feel as though you had to
get in front of it what really made you
think this is
this is something that i got to stop
before it gets roots
well you were seeing it sprout up across
the country
and you were seeing it sprout up in some
of these woke corporations as well
and you know we felt very strongly that
our tax dollars
should not be going to teaching these
theories that are not based in fact
and that really divide people and is
effectively a form of state-sanctioned
racism so
we had huge support in doing that people
from all walks of life
and i think you're seeing that
throughout the country and so i know
that there's
still some people on the far left who
are trying to justify this
but i think you're seeing americans
really come together and say
we do not want this in our schools
governor i know you're sending law
enforcement to patrol
the border because the vice president
and the president haven't gone down
there so states are having to act alone
and you're so it's very kind of you to
help you're not the only state but to
help those folks are border patrol
agents who need all the help they can
get ralph norman is a republican from
south carolina he's a congressman
and he was in he was uh he was grilling
alejandro mayorkas the secretary of
homeland security it was the house
homeland
security meeting yesterday morning and
he was testifying and he was asking him
why isn't the vice president going down
there listen to this
i'm reclaiming my time you made the
statement that my question was unfair
i'm making the statement that your
comments are just words and they're very
unfair i ask you a simple question and i
would like for you just to
answer simply uh does it make sense
for the leaders of the free world to go
in to talk to and see what's going on at
the border i am the secretary of
homeland security
and it is my responsibility
to manage the border at the direction of
the president and the vice president
and i have visited the border on
multiple occasions the vice president
served as the attorney general of a
border state
of california and she is quite familiar
uh with the situation on the border
she's laughing
so your officers governor are going to
go to the border before the vice
president who is basically the border
czar
well the sad thing about this is the
federal government has just completely
abdicated its responsibility we had
policies under president trump that were
working
the border was under control and biden
comes in and they knowingly
uh revoked all these policies knowing
what was going to happen
and now they're just showing really a
callous disregard and it's not just
those border communities that are being
affected obviously they are
one of the things we're dealing with in
places particularly some of our rural
counties
is the meth and it's all coming from
across the southern border the cartels
are absolutely eating biden and harris's
lunch
and the fact that she won't even go down
there but look
what greg abbott's doing doug ducey
they're stepping up and filling a void
where the federal government has left
this lack of leadership and so when they
asked for support
i felt it was the right thing to do that
florida would be there to help them out
they've helped us out in the past when
we've had
emergencies and natural disasters but
the idea that we're even having to do
this
is really a sad commentary on the lack
of federal leadership we're seeing
and the attorney general of the great
state of florida supports you
in this move and uh she pointed out
yesterday 21 floridians die
every day because of opioids and that's
why it's a crisis and we need to stop
them from coming into the country
governor if you you've been in
washington you're there in florida and
tallahassee
explain the politics if you would this
has been your business for a while
explain the politics on how somebody at
the white house
thought it was a good idea to put her in
charge of this
and not have her go and see it with her
own two eyes
i think that they they realize it's a
disaster and i think they think if if
she goes it's just going to highlight it
even more
but i'll tell you not showing up not
taking decisive action is ultimately
it's the bad policy response ultimately
politically it's not going to work i
mean
people are fed up with this they want to
see action this is the federal
government's responsibility
and you have all of us in the states now
having to step up and do their job for
them just want to point this out when
you were in congress
then senator kamala harris went to
homestead to point out that there were
kids
coming across the border being placed in
facilities like this and she was
concerned about their condition what
happened to that concern
it's amazing how things seem to change
based on uh
where they're sitting but of course they
were just using that
to try to attack donald trump that was
the only reason they were doing it
that's why they've
done these policies because they think
trump is bad if he did it it must be bad
they've got to do the opposite
that's not good leadership i mean good
leadership is doing what's best for the
country
and obviously she is failing in that
regard and so is the president
i know you just recently signed a bill
to give police dogs priority medical
help tell us more about this
well we're actually you guys are getting
the preview because i'm going to
transition out of this interview do the
press conference we're here at the st
johns county sheriff's office we'll be
signing the bill probably in the next 30
minutes
and yeah we will and what it does is we
have
these these canines that are that are on
the front lines protecting
us they perform valuable functions and
yet under florida law
if they're injured in the line of duty
they could not be transported
and would buy emt personnel like like an
officer would be able to
and this bill changes that this gives
them that emergency those emergency
services
they're going to be able to be
transported and and hopefully
that will be enough to potentially save
some of the canines lives because i mean
you'll have some of these assailants
they'll try to shoot the dogs and
they'll do a lot of really bad things
so we've really i think leaned in and we
also in florida we've got a number of
great organizations
that are involved in training dogs we
have we have organizations that train
dogs
for service members suffering from ptsd
and a whole host of things so we're
really proud
of what florida does to stand by our
four-legged friends
all right and you're going to be signing
that bill very shortly um
governor let's change from a news
channel to the golf channel
yesterday you actually posted your
three-year-old son mason and people love
to golf in florida but usually they
start when they're like 30 or 40.
he's three and he can really drive that
ball what did you post
as the uh caption under mason's picture
there
well i said the guy is three years old
and he's already got a better swing than
his old man does and uh
you know i'm somebody i work at it when
i can i
you know i have a baseball background so
i used to swing but but he is just
and my daughter madison is really good
too they they just have great hand-eye
coordination great
clubhead speed but he is obsessed with
hitting golf balls and baseballs he does
it all day long and i think you see in
that i mean he's hitting
yeah that's like a nine iron he's
hitting that 50
60 yards as a three-year-old kid and
he's got nice straight maybe a little
bit of a fade and so uh
i think he's got a great future if
that's what he wants to do you know
what's amazing is that he has no rituals
the ball goes down he just hits it you
know people are always getting settings
getting set but it's no surprise really
because you met your wife
on the driving range didn't you and
isn't casey a great a really good golfer
she is she's a great athlete she was a
college equestrian
scholarship and um we were just happen
to be at the driving range
next to each other she's whacking balls
where's mason here come here buddy
she's whacking balls i got him right
here um and so uh yeah
show them how you hit the ball sure sure
it's a little bit early for them but um
but yeah so we did that and we've it's
been something that we've enjoyed
together and these kids i think um
really uh are fortunate that they've got
they've got a mother who's uh
very good-looking and very athletic and
so i think they're getting everything
from her side
there's your whole family right there
that that's good you can write off this
uh appearance
oh madison wave wave to the camera now
madison now madison
when i had a chance to spend the day
with you governor that one of the first
things that's happened your kids are
running around the house in control
having fun
but you were able to show me madison
swing take a look at this swing
watch you missed the first one but you
hit like five in a row
uh you're making the most of the
governor's mansion
so this is an athletic fan no we we
we've got we've got an ability to do all
kind of athletics all around the mansion
compound and these kids take advantage
of it
but that's kind of uh you know we we
have to learn when we're dealing with
the young kids
they may put finger paint on the on the
wallpaper in the state dining room we
gotta troubleshoot they may do this they
may do that
so it's kind of a constant effort to
keep keep one step ahead of them there
was one that was in the bowl
on top of the sideboard in the dining
room yeah which one was that
was that mamie well actually we ended up
getting
both uh when you all came when brian
came but the um
the reason that happened the last time
there was a baby in the mansion was over
50 years ago and they took a picture
of the governor's then baby son in there
so when we came
in we put mason in and got him to do a
picture
and then they both jumped in when brian
was down a few months ago
so governor you're gonna have a poll
just trust me you're gonna have a hard
time it's
you work a lot now and people are
helping you when they start having games
and after school activities you're gonna
have a hard time running press
conferences
knowing they're playing baseball golf
soccer football whatever
oh no no no we we will not be scheduling
press conferences during any of their
games i'll make sure that
that i'm at the gate so we'll figure out
a way to make that work you will be the
only parent with a police escort
to little league you know what uh we
were talking about this earlier
we've actually because your son mason
who obviously gets his
athletic prowess from your wife is so
good at golf we've we've put together a
side-by-side comparison of mason
at three with a very young tiger woods
tiger woods when he was a little boy
uh showed up on i believe the mike
douglas show and this
you know stunning
the similarities between your child and
tiger woods who lives in
jupiter florida you have a monitor there
governor
i know but they did show it to me before
i got on and so
you know it's pretty neat to see i mean
i don't think there's anyone that's been
a better golf prodigy than tiger he's a
very special guy
but you never know i mean you know when
they when they start i think golf if you
start young it really does help
because it builds the muscle memory i
didn't start playing until i was in my
mid-20s after my baseball career was
over
i had the hand-eye coordination but it
is a little bit different swing he's
very comfortable
with just getting that club face on the
ball and giving it a ride and so we look
forward to seeing what he can do in the
future
and he's comfortable being on television
he's totally natural
and governor we wanted to put brian did
play some golf
with president bush and we wanted to
compare his swing oh
you you're dead we did not want to
compare my swing
yours is not bad it's not bad i am so
stiff it's not bad but i think mason
might be better i saw i said they showed
me that before too
brian i think he got i think he got good
technique i mean i would dog you if you
didn't i i was uh i think it was a good
swing
it's wired up he's very positive he
thinks it might be a potential voter
so he knows i think it all worked out
well for you you're doing okay all right
governor thanks for the kind words
all right uh so we got to talk about
politics we talked about dogs and we
talked about his life that's right uh
can we have mason just wait goodbye
if the governor is still there i guess
all right goodbye to the camera bye
mason
say bye bye bye bye it's early good
have a good weekend governor thank you